the Trump administration faces new legal
challenges over the national emergency
declaration to pay for a wall on the
us-mexico border the American Civil
Liberties Union filed a lawsuit
yesterday a group of 16 states filed a
separate suit Monday that called the
emergency declaration unconstitutional
several landowners on the border are
also fighting back media video is in
Mission Texas with how properties are
now at risk Media good morning well good
morning this part of South Texas is
where that proposed border wall could
end up being built some landowners have
already received notices of surveys
others letters to buy their property at
one point though there are some people
that are fighting back as you just said
suing the government to keep what is
rightfully theirs it's been about six
seven generations of not more this small
1 acre piece of land along the Rio
Grande River was left to Yvette Gaitan
by her father it's now at risk of being
taken away by the government for a new
border wall so she's suing the Trump
administration to keep it I'm fighting
his idea of what he thinks we need
they're gonna take what I have left of
my parents last week the Department of
Defense released a statement saying the
national emergency declaration
authorizes the Secretary of Defense to
determine whether border barriers are
necessary I hope it's a wake-up call for
all Americans that this administration
that purports to be all about law and
order is in fact lawless Mariana Trevino
Wright is the executive director of the
national butterfly center a facility
that could lose about 70 acres of land
so the land behind me actually belongs
to the national butterfly center but
over here to my left this is property
that belongs to the federal government
it's a National Preserve these signs
just went up last week warning people
they cannot go beyond this yellow lie
it's restricted because inevitably this
is where new portions of the border wall
will be built a lawsuit filed by the
butterfly center in 2017 to stop the
wall was dismissed last week is there a
fear that that this might be what's in
store for other land owners I think it's
a very real possibility and they should
be prepared for the worst so why fight
for it
because it means everything to me that
means everything to me to my kids my
sons saw my dad as more of as a father
than a grandfather and to know that
they're gonna lose the last bit that we
have of him it's not easy the love with
the chapel is right behind me it was
actually spared in that funding
compromise from last week but right now
with this national emergency declaration
they say that they are not out of the
woods yet we did reach out to the White
House the Department of Defense and DHS
all of them would not comment about
these lawsuits John Moran thank you